again this in a way is an excuse like
with that women use because if he hasn't
seen a therapist and he hasn't been
professionally diagnosed you can't
diagnose him as a narcissist i think
it's difficult because i know it's it's
not it's not difficult you know it's
like if he if he's not hasn't been
diagnosed as a narcissist we can't just
go around calling people narcissists so
i'm going to say narcissistic traits
what that means is that a person is
coming across a certain way but they're
not diagnosed i apologize if anyone
takes offense to that i think i want to
answer pearl's question um with regards
to what are the mistakes women make
um in becoming aware of so i think
personally
today's women think that identifying
with feminism is a good long-term
strategy
and it's clearly not because
as you said men appreciate youth men
appreciate fertility so i think the
biggest problem of feminism for me is
that
feminism encourages independence right
and in today's society for females
independence means in my opinion
incredibly promiscuous
so they end up sleeping with multiple
guys thinking they do the same thing as
men because normally independence mean
you can do what you want right by
yourself
but it's clearly not working out for
anyone i mean all the statistics about
i mean what age of women getting married
now what age of women having kids now
like it's not working out for women at
all so go ahead can i make sure that
that video i mean
is it a big deal like what they were
mentioning
they were exaggerating
it's like the light thing like come on
that's what i was saying
what if he was like let me just try to
guess this benefit concentrated so yeah
this is the issue
actually it's like someone
yeah like the point is that girls make
every sob story out of everything
i don't understand why that's a i'm
sorry i might be a bit slow but i
genuinely don't understand and then but
you see the men you see the men enabling
them too yeah because the man the men
are saying oh like all you have to do is
be nice to a girl but it's funny because
the girl the second guy the girl was
just using
like she was using for attention he
walked away after the date
then she wanted the attention got a set
like got another date out of him and
then i was like
this is what we have to speak about a
little bit
this is where we have to speak about men
a bit because i think men
i think there's a lot of delusional men
too as much as i'm this probably the
only bit i'll stick up for me so i might
as well get out of the way now um
i've seen men
in just just going out nightclubs and
such i've seen men get upset when they
can't get the baddest girl in the club
and i'm looking at them thinking like
what do you what are you what's what are
you are you average looking dude for
starters do you have swag do you have
money and you're upset that you can't
get the baddest girl in a club like
it's like
yeah there's a lot of delusional men too
i can't just throw it all on women i've
seen so many things in my life right i'm
just looking at dude like you're not
going to get that [ __ ] i got a question
for you son
so you mentioned earlier you like to
bring up to um to women you know just
look in the mirror right
well i'm not sure about down south but
where i'm from up north
most of the women and i'm sure anyone
from the north would agree with me i
ratchet right
and um if you even start to bring up
accountability they will fly off the
handle and it will not end well for you
know like even if you put your foot down
they'll throw a pan at your head you
know what i mean so they're crazy so
what what would be your advice for the
you asked me how to draw women because i
can give you the crazy i can give you a
quick strategy but i i i know how to get
well i got a shoulder hey go ahead go
ahead i can give you the i can't give
any guy that's watching
how to get a girl in a nightclub anyway
if you want to know that like okay this
is the most simplest method that's
worked for me
when i was single by the way
so
i got multiple examples i do me and my
friends do this [ __ ] all the time right
so you see a girl that you're attracted
to at the bar right
i walk up
there's a there's a long queue i use my
structure i use my stance i use my size
not gonna lie i walk right to the front
i'd be like you got were you guys
drinking i'll tell you want to drink i
said cool no worries don't say another
word right
go to the bar order my drink order them
a drink
give it to them and walk off
and i i promise you yeah the amount of
times
them same girls think what the fighting
ask me for my number didn't ask my
snapchat what the hell i literally go
cool walk off here they find you that
same night boy reverse like because
you're you're you're you you're making
them think you're adding adding some
sort of like doubt in the world why why
not speaking why aren't you asking my
number like just walk off and then
obviously there's got to be something
about you though i don't want to tell
like some any dude you can just do this
and it's going to be successful like you
have to have something about you like me
and my friends we're very [ __ ] we go out
all over the uk simple we get a table
vip that's it because as we know
american culture uk culture they
appreciate
women appreciate that but it depends on
your goal they're trying to find a wifey
that's one thing you're trying to have
fun that night that's another thing but
i think when men give it all out on the
table there and then women are not
interested because they know that what
they can get from they're in this like
yeah even even the one guy in the
reaction video he said like just don't
touch her yeah we're about to see
the last two videos in that uh that
video the tick tock videos was guys
basically ignoring them and the ladies
were like i've never been more attracted
in my life
so uh
it's just you always want what you can't
have that's why what what are the most
ridiculous standards that you've heard
men and women say
men on the women yeah so so give me like
it doesn't have to be that high maybe
you haven't heard one that's that high
for one or the other but for a man to
like wife a girl and for a girl to wipe
to marry a guy what are like the highest
standards you've heard a girl and a guy
say
um well
one of them has got to be a single
mother talking to me and saying like oh
i want this i want this i want this out
of the guy like
specifically um
you know just having money having a car
uh having his own house and
you know accommodate yeah how old was he
she was like my age 19. she want to do
with the house yeah yeah so um and maybe
she wasn't on about right now but
regardless of the age it's
it's very rarely going to happen on this
if you're going to find a simp okay
right and we all know how that's gonna
end now what about the most picky guy
you know
uh the most picky guy um
i don't really think i know that many
people
okay okay fair enough
i'll start off with the guys i i know
some guys that are very picky
and they don't have the qualities
to be that picky
so i've heard guys like 30 plus talking
about my girl can't have more than three
bodies my girl got more than four bodies
and i'm like i mean first of all what
are you offering you still look at your
mom's crib like have you got your own
paper like have you got your own crib no
so how are you asking a girl you're
trying to find a girl that's only got
three bodies what does that mean
how many people have had sex with yeah
uh for women i mean i've seen some bang
average looking women
talk about i want a guy that's got six
figures i want a guy that's got his own
crippling that
if my guy's still living at his mom's
house at 22 20 i don't want and i'm
looking at me thinking right okay what
do you have to offer
i think i'm very blessed that i surround
myself with wonderful people and i'll be
very honest from a personal level
i have i see many
beautiful examples of relationships that
work really really well
men and women so for me i
it would just be quoting things on the
internet to be honest so you've never
heard anyone in real life have a am i
because i have high standards of people
that i surround myself with so that's
why so no answer okay
pretty much the usual like six figure
and all that stuff but the craziest one
i had was the the 200k engagement ring
oh from
not just oh i forgot that oh yeah oh my
lord she literally wants a house on her
finger i can't imagine that that's just
the engagement ring that's not even a
wedding no i'm cheap you see
so i just couldn't imagine even if i had
the money i would never spend 200k on an
engagement ring and i was actually
thinking about it today this morning
like pearl is advertising so she wants a
man who can afford that but then doesn't
she respect him like
she doesn't connect you could tour
europe and see all of europe india like
you could go all around the world for
200k you're going to spend that on a
range yeah and a smart a smart guy who
has made that money by himself is not
going to spend that money at all
on a ring that is the that is the worst
investment as a business when you could
make it's just not worth it so she gains
his respect by building this wealth and
then she loses it like he loses the
respect by making such a bad presence oh
what if she lost the rig
oh my gosh
oh my god i don't even like wearing
expensive jewelry
can we talk about in london i genuinely
had to tell one of my friends from hong
kong who has a big-ish ring for uk
standards which is not big for us but
big for uk
and i actually told her to please can
you swing your ring around because you
are going to get your finger chopped off
yeah you don't know it's it's like why
are you she was traveling why are you
wearing this
wear it at home but also i personally
think that people are like they just
think they they're doing it for their
ego so they want to look flashy they
want to look amazing right usually these
people are broke by the way because they
spend they spend it all on stuff that
they then wear rather than put it in
their wealth and then they and then they
they cry when they get
mugged they get robbed like
well
you're the one who's literally
advertising yourself unfortunately in a
certain way and
girls don't like hearing that you if you
dress a certain way you're gonna attract
a certain type of attention the same
breath say uh i can protect myself and i
don't need a man
that's the problem because if you get if
you're a female you get robbed you're
the first person you're gonna call